following a leak the next batch of
PlayStation Plus premium and extra games
have been officially announced this list
includes Heavy Hitters like Horizon
forbidden West Borderlands 3 and Scarlet
Nexus Horizon forbidden West is a big
get for the higher tiers of the
PlayStation Plus subscription service as
the game launched a year ago on
PlayStation 5 and Playstation 4. A PS5
exclusive expansion burning Shores is
also in development and is scheduled to
arrive on April 19th Scarlet Nexus is
also a fairly recent game while
Borderlands 3 and Resident Evil 7 are
older but popular titles other games
featured in this batch are the Quarry
Tekken 7 Ace Combat 7 Sky's unknown and
the Forgotten City and the best part is
you won't have to wait long to take
advantage of these additions because
they'll be available next week on
February 21st PlayStation Plus has added
some big name games in recent months
with February's lineup including the
skateboarding Adventure olly olly world
that action-packed Mafia definitive
edition multiplayer horror in the form
of Evil Dead the game and Destiny's 2
2020 expansion Beyond light at the basic
tier of the service it is also worth
reminding you that PlayStation Plus has
also announced that the PlayStation Plus
collection will be removed on May 9th
not to be confused with the game catalog
that we spoke about at the top of this
video the PlayStation Plus collection
was a handful of PS4 hit games such as
bloodborne and Uncharted 4 and many more
that were offered to PlayStation 5
owners as a bonus when the console first
launched make sure you claim all those
games if you haven't already in other
news Square Enix has confirmed that the
Final Fantasy VII DLC for powerbot
simulator will officially release on
March 2nd for PC and last gen and
current gen consoles as well as switch
announced earlier this year the add-on
will take players through the streets of
midgar while they'll be tasked with
completing some tough and filthy levels
only a few teasers were given during
initial reveal but Square Enix has
expanded on what you can expect from
this free DLC this isn't the first time
that power wash simulator has done a
video game crossover as the game added
Lara croft's mud encrusted Mansion to
its Library recently the Tomb Raider DLC
is free on both consoles and PC and
speaking of free things the free update
for the second season of Modern Warfare
2 and Warzone 2 is alive and Activision
has revealed the patch notes season 2
includes a ton of weapons balancing the
m13b assault rifle was buffed to
increase damage at mid-range and provide
increased upper torso damage while the
popular attack the battle rifle received
major Nerfs Apache nodes also detail
additional tuning available in the
gunsmith for season 2. tuning has been
enabled for laser attachments and the
tuning sliders have been updated for
numerous attachments for the full list
of patch notes head on over to
gamespot.com let me know in the comments
what tier of PlayStation Plus you're
subscribed to I was at premium I was
thinking of going down to essential but
now I guess I'll stay right in the
middle at extra at least for like
another month
I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]